mobile apps are changing the world
android was introduced by google in 2007
and is the most popular smartphone
operating system on the planet today
and now android development is kotlin
first
and now you can learn directly from
google professionals in the new android
kotlin developer nanodegree program from
udacity
the nanodegree program is built by
industry and for industry
because udacity doesn't just teach you a
programming language
we give you all the skills needed to
land a job
the program prepares students for a
career as a professional
android kotlin developer anyone starting
a new project
should write it in kotlin because code
written in kotlin means much less code
less code to type test and maintain
you'll learn by developing real-world
hands-on projects
including an advanced android
application that utilizes google maps to
provide
key location based updates master kotlin
first
android development and get equipped to
build the next industry-defining killer
app for the world's most used mobile
platform
enroll in udacity's new android kotlin
developer nanodegree program today